you didn't have anything or experiences
before this whole story do you think
that means that anyone can potentially
unlock this power everybody's psychic
every single person is psychic and when
I looked back on my childhood I was able
to go back and reframe certain moments
where I was like oh oh that was a
psychic thing you know and I always go
back I tell the story at my events all
the time when I was in fourth grade Mrs
worthley was the fourth grade teacher
and she would give us our 10 vocabulary
words to study and then you would like
have to spell your 10 vocabulary words
and you always got an extra credit word
so her desk was in the far left of the
classroom my desk was in a row that was
closest to the entrance all the way in
the back and she gave us the 10 words
and we did it and then she gave us an
extra credit word and the extra credit
word was fleem fourth grade fleem so I
looked up and I saw on the chalkboard p
hle e GM so I was like and I wrote it
down so then there was a parent teaching
conference and they wanted to know who
was teaching me medical terminology
in like at my age because why would a
fourth grader know how to spell fem
everybody else in the class spelled it f
FM my mom was a stickler for lying she
had a she her her thing was if you do
something wrong you tell me before I
find out from somebody else you're not
going to get in trouble I find out from
somebody else you're in bigger trouble
than you can possibly imagine and don't
lie so that was always like a thing so
I'm I got called into the meeting and
the teacher said how would you know and
I looked at him and I said you wrote it
on the board and the teacher said I did
not write it on the board and my mom
like looked at me so I had the moment
and I just like looked at the teacher
and I went she's lying like she's lying
right now but now when I thought about
it as an adult or as a teenager I was
like wait there's no logical way Mrs
Worley would get from her desk to the
board to write it in the time that she
said it I just took it for granted she
said it I looked up I saw it I wrote it
down and then I realized I had a lot of
those moments but I never looked at them
as being psychic they were just moments
they were just moments of like you have
experiences and that's why I tell people
when someone loses a loved one and
they're like I'm not getting any signs
I'm not feeling anything I'm not seeing
anything I'm like you are you just don't
know how to call it or how to phrase it
or how to how to how to like dissect it
from the the mess of everything else
that's happening amongst the
grief
I